bienvenue à la maison
Je sais que cet endroit n'est pas seulement chaleureux comme je l'
espérais
mais je vais allumer une bougie à la vanille
et ça va changer la donne
nous sommes sortis
ce manoir est déséquilibré
les espoirs que vous pouvez obtenir vous voulez  être un
héros
passer deux mille dollars quelle est l'
adresse
[Applaudissements]
une maison sans fenêtres
[Musique]
ça va aider
cette maison a une façon de vous jouer des tours
oh mon Dieu est-ce que quelqu'un d'autre voit ça
ouais ouais je suis  en le voyant,
d'autres entités plus puissantes peuvent
apparaître pas sous notre surveillance qu'est-ce que tu
vas faire
sérieusement ouais ils sont déjà morts
tu vas être plus mort d'accord
[Musique]